Irish man you know what I can't wake up
right now with laying down Irishmen
trailer dropped called up John he jetted
back we're gonna watch this trailer so
excited for this you best bet I'm gonna
be watching this Netflix movie in the
theaters
oh man cannot wait cannot wait why are
we wasting any more time all these
impressions
[Music]
[Music]
it was Harvey
we gotta sit down everybody
my god
it's gonna happen either way he's going
[Music]
that makes no difference to me right the
de-aging does look better in motion
definitely better in motion and it is
just on the photos a little intense
about this you never know I just don't
understand if you're a fan of light
cinema if you grew up on Scorsese films
Pacino De Niro how can you not be
excited for this movie I just don't know
how you you can't possibly be except for
the only thing I can see possibly to
tearing people is the worrisome effect
of it is the AG thing gonna be a
distraction because it looks like for
the most part it's in the younger years
or at least you know before what their
actual age is now specifically De Niro
you know like there's a fair amount that
they can probably play yeah in the later
years of these guys lives where they can
just make up stuff and then yeah the
more extreme bits we're gonna do yeah
but yeah in motion at least a good
amount of it looked pretty alright in
this trailer I mean there are only a
couple moments where I was maybe like I
don't know been other movies where we've
had to readjust to it and when you do
you do you know and and this is the
movies based off the book I hear you
paint houses this trailer really gave me
the vibe of that because when I heard
that was the title of it I'm like are
you paint and then okay I get it you
know it's like slaying hidden code or
something like that for killing someone
right that's just what I'm assuming it's
about starting off the trailer with what
I'm assuming Ray Romano yeah yeah it
says right there attorney yeah so ray
romano playing the attorney character
and then they're coming up with you know
all the lies the covers whatever going
off of that title of the book I hear you
paint houses and seeing you know the all
the different words they're using that
are really referring to actual criminal
activity okay yeah that's part of a
crime story like this because this is
mort's even further toward the line
between crime and the establishment you
know you have labor unions and the
government involved with this end all
the trickery that goes around with that
side of crime with these I don't know it
seems cool because you're gonna have
that gangster double speak but in a
totally different environment than just
being a straight-up gangster scenario
sure true cuz like all this stuff with
the labor unions is fascinating in and
of itself and like so many other
people's lives are affected because of
what this is yeah and this felt like
Shore vintage Scorsese territory
especially with kind of the the music
that was playing over this trailer just
picking up on some you know potential
plot point beats that I am familiar with
other Scorsese flicks it looks like you
know this got its family themes yeah
obviously in its in its crime family
themes and the difference between who
you are at home versus who you are like
at your work yeah exactly and then also
it seems like you know there'll be a
large portion of this is probably you
know feeling really lavish in a
lifestyle we're living it up and seeing
the benefits that come with it and being
you know someone who works for Jimmy
Hoffa directly and seeing the
perspective of how you sort of have a
sort of idolize this guy and you know
what made Jimmy Hoffa's such an
appealing character to people and such a
divisive figure too right and then it
seems like as it progresses and then you
know they talked about like big business
and government getting involved in the
politics and everything it would
eventually evolved into you know
Scorsese paranoia which is one of the
things I love that he deals with so well
it's like the editing starts getting
faster yeah so there's a lot more moving
shots there like you see like Pacino
losing it at the end they're all talking
about Joe Pesci and err or talking about
how he's gonna be he has to go down
eventually it just has to have these
crossroads here that's like De Niro's
characters kind of just in the middle of
this he doesn't feel like the middle man
and and that's often a fascinating place
to be because you can trudge the moral
gray areas between two polls in a very
charged situation like Jimmy Hoffa has
taken on this larger-than-life quality
because of the circumstances of his
death disappearance etc and so you had
to see a character it's almost like a
twisted version of a gat
because you're seeing it through
somebody who works yes records with him
and then we can see the fans that kind
of helps you with the fantasy side of
with the fact side to where there might
be inconsistencies or whatever you know
because you're through this guy's
perspective but yeah it also looks like
it has that sort of narration quality or
it's like we're gonna hear from his
perspective I'm talking about like you
know something about like oh we were the
garbage men basically or what a metal
yeah this or says he voiceover yeah yeah
yeah and so like that's just one of
those classics that you like I'm excited
to hear one of ether gear you see like
Pesci and De Niro and Harvey Keitel all
sitting around at the table talking with
each other I'm like oh it's so cool have
all them back together once again one
weirdly like Joe Pesci now is the one
where I really want to see like a full
scene that features him because I feel
like the trailers have mostly cut his
clips relatively short because you know
DeNiro is the Irishman and yeah Pacino
is Hoffa but uh there's a lot of Ray
Romano looks really funny yeah yeah and
I love that he's even in this point of
his career being able to do these kinds
of things where he's playing on his
funny awkward Ray Romano quality but it
worked perfectly in this scenario and
especially quality lawyers often take on
especially in crime related movies like
he's like great casting and that's part
of the fun of a Scorsese flick like this
too is not only like the heavies you get
in the leads but also the cool character
actors he brings on the sides I've
noticed a lot of the shots aren't as a
score sighs it tends to shoot a lot in
the wide and this seems to be a really
up-close and personal
it seems like rather intimate mm-hm can
really get those de-aging to you yeah I
mean if you pay attention to a lot of
the way he frames his films and since
terms of cinematography this looks a
little bit different yeah I feel like
that and probably in terms of editing
pacing music it'll be what we are
familiar with with his type of style
without dealing with this genre
especially he's also spanning what looks
like decades of a person's life I mean
you got super young girls who like to
hear other than what did you yeah yeah I
imagine it's gonna feel different I
think what happens a lot with you know
this kind of trailer is people will be
going
oh this reminds me of Goodfellas
Goodfellows days casino and stuff but I
think that's gonna be a little bit
different obviously there'll be some
familiarities there however this was the
story at hand I think people will be
surprised what's gonna come yeah and I
imagine this is kind of an obvious thing
to say but I am getting that sense of
further maturity through this it's like
yeah it does make you think of those
movies because of course there's you
know things that are similar but this
does feel like an older more learn in
persons movie arguably and one thing I
love about Scorsese as he's aged is he
has remained really thoughtful over yes
as well as you know a guy who can do all
these things that we think are awesome
and so yeah to see all these dudes to
bringing that age to their roles you
know and to those younger scenes even is
a really cool prospect the acting is
just as exciting as the directing is as
exciting as you know what the story is
gonna be all right guys well you excited
for the Irishman I mean I hope you are
especially if you're here with us right
now you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
relegate notified whenever got a YouTube
video I would like to end this with a
patron of the day shout out to pursue
spent a patron for quite some time but
recently up there pledged everyone could
take a note from her everyone and then
stress us out of I'm making sure we
could hit everyone shout out by the end
of the month there are only so many Katy
and over here thank you so much I had
her up on messages home girl gave me a
biopic perfectly suited for the Irishman
which is a biopic of sorts she's from
New York like the Irish mazi Wow it was
your perfect company she's a huge
cinephile she really wanted to depth
talk with me about you know how she was
like looking for more channels that
really share that same kind of passion
enthusiasm compassion and I just want to
say Katie you came to the wrong channel
this is a major letdown to you there's
so many there's a better chance you
could have been to but but do stay
pledged for as long as you can she's
super into the arts herself she you know
paints she does poetry I hope you write
me a poem that I could share publicly
and then my ex-girlfriends threaten you
for sending me something so sweet oh
yeah that's gonna and then top it off
with a photo of you
doing your new yoga which would just
have my girlfriend fly over to you and
murder you and then enroll a mouse in
your place yeah we'll take one of those
we're gonna go to bed